The joe rogan experience.
Why was it all being covered up?
It's fucking insane.
When you find out why he has a for dead
bodies in general,
the key people,
why he loved fucking dead people.
What'd you hear this then surgery,
the ninth circle on these of congruent
to watch that Jesus Christ.
It's insane.
When you find out when you watch that
shit dude,
it is crazy that you like you're saying
this and it sounds like like they can
never be possible.
It sounds like it never,
it could be possible that some giant
television star that worked with
children and it was always helping out.
Children could have actually been
fucking them the whole time and a bunch
of them,
hundreds of raping them and then people
must have known there's no way he was
killing them too.
He was killing him.
He was killing it,
dude.
They got,
they found all these bodies.
It's a box.
It's a big scandal in the UK.
Hold up right now,
dude.
Jesus Christ.
There's an island called Jersey island
that's owned by the Queen and look into
that shit.
I don't even want to get that.
I don't even want to get that deep into
it because that I don't have a rape
children as young as nine while working
at BBC leaked report on veils.
And this is in the independent.
Yeah.
How come,
how come there's not the same kind of
effort for this kind of stuff like there
is with the um,
um,
the gun shooting,
the Florida school shooting.
Why isn't there that?
Cause that's not a big event where it's
one thing we're,
all the deaths happen in one deaths or
deaths.
I understand.
I'm with you.
But I mean this is also why people don't
freak out about 500,000 people dying
every year because of obesity.
Like what would you,
what's worse?
What's worse?
Having your kid get shot at a school
shooting or having that motherfucker
rape your daughter and multiple times
and then kill.
I don't think what's worse,
they're both hard.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's horrible.
It's just what's scary is that that is
being protected.
Yes.
There's someone that either knew about
it and now it's trying to cover their
ass because they knew about it.
That was the thing about Sandusky.
Y'All saying Guskey did the same thing.
He was raping all these kids and the
whole time he was running these programs
for underprivileged children and helping
all these orphaned kids,
you've got to watch your kids,
man.
You got to watch it till he got away
with abusing 500 children and sex with
dead bodies.
Whoa.
You know what a death ride is?
Death ride,
death ride.
No.
Jimmy savile.
What's,
uh,
supply 10,
15 boys to a certain politician.
Um,
he'd have a boat.
He'd take him out on the boat.
He could,
he couldn't afford to have any
witnesses.
So those were always the last rides.
Those kids would take their called death
rides,
cheese.
It couldn't have.
This is from that same documentary.
Ninth Circle C but how do they know that
for a fact?
You just got to watch it and,
and uh,
and make the,
uh,
conclusion.
Yeah.
Dot.
That's magnified when you have children
because they have no say,
well that's the other buildings.
They put their kids out there and I'm
like,
well,
okay.
I don't know.
I'm not saying it's the worst thing to
do,
but it's not the child's choice.
And they're very young and you're making
your look like whoever did what they did
to Michael Jackson,
right?
Yeah.
One of the things that they did is they
made him famous way before he had any
idea what the fuck that meant.
And they profited off of it.
Yeah.
They kind of pimped them out.
Right?
Yeah.
And that's kind of what's happening and
the story to them.
Yeah.
Ultimately the whole thing destroyed
him.
Right.
And um,
I just,
I don't want to be a part of that.
there's no think that's smart.
I don't think it's intelligent.
And I also don't,
this is my real honest feelings.
I do not think that fame is a,
I don't think that people should aspire
to it.
I think it should be something that
happens if people like your work and
then it's cool,
it's fine,
but I think there's way too much
emphasis put on just trying to get
attention and it's being rewarded and
supported in this weird way.
There's nothing wrong with getting
attention,
but it should make sense.
It should make sense.
There should be some reason and if it's
out of balance,
yeah.
You know you should,
you should probably look at like why,
why is it that
balance like,
yeah and lots of things that attract
attention or not things that we need.
Why we want more of,
you know,
like conflict.
Yes,
conflict.
That's a big one.
But it's also the,
I like just fame itself.
One of the weirdest parts about it is
that you have to constantly be checking
yourself.
Like all these people are nice to you.
All these people are saying nice things
to you or being mean to you.
You know,
one of the,
like they've all people that you don't
even know,
so you can't rely on them for your self
esteem and you certainly can't rely on
them for criticism.
You can't rely on them and people you
don't even know that don't care about
you,
you know,
so you,
you,
you're in this weird position.
You have to be very careful with who you
communicate with because one of the
weirdest things you'll see from famous
people is all the sudden they get this
very strange thing where they feel like
people were supposed to do things for
them and you know,
they don't,
they're not supposed to pay for things
and everything's supposed to be easy and
they're supposed to get that.
That's a,
that's a weird one.
Like they,
they don't respond to criticism.
Well,
they don't understand that there's still
a human being in the middle of growth.
No.
There a fucking star.
I'm a fucking star and I want this and I
want it now.
Yeah.
And they just like,
what kind of fucking bullshit is this?
Do you know who I am?
Yeah,
exactly.
What we've seen.
We've all seen like a version of that.
Right.
And Rob about it.
The problem though is that
they
no,
that their shit stinks.
Yes.
They know that they're human.
They know.
So they're so then they develop this
sort of,
um,
fraud,
a phobia that people are going to find
out what they really are.
Yeah.
That's weird.
It hurts us.
It's also weird,
like the UFC could just,
did they just decide who's fighting?
I mean it's the whole thing.
The business is so interesting because
it's like they decide who's fighting.
They decide who's champion.
They decide,
Tony,
you're not champion anymore.
I'm going to strip yet.
It's like put it all fell.
I was,
I don't want this to,
he's up at Fox studios.
I twist my knee,
but he was working for the UFC when he
fell.
I mean he's doing his,
his obligations,
his press obligation.
It's very strange to strip him of a belt
when he never lost it.
And here's the longest winning streak
and then and mean,
but also happiness.
No belt,
no belt can be.
It was going to take the belt.
They going to make up a bell.
And then connor has the belt at 55.
So what do you do with that belt?
Well what they're planning on doing,
I believe,
and now they've kind of let the cat out
of the bag because he said it's going to
be for the world lightweight title.
They were going to strip connor the
moment something happened,
like the moment the fight started.
That's when they were going to strip
connor.
Yeah,
because if they'd stripped him
beforehand,
then what happens if Tony doesn't make
weight or something totally makes
[inaudible] doesn't make weight.
Then what the fuck do you check?
Concern,
then you have nothing.
You already stripped him.
We're going to give it back to him.
I'm going to give it back to them.
No.
If he wants to fight again now,
he's not the champion anymore.
The fuck kind of Shit is strange.
So they waited and the idea was to wait,
but now they're going to desperado
situation.
Desperado so belt on the line had
fucking April fool's.
April fool's day,
it happens.
I didn't believe a God damn word of it.
Jimmy Smith's starts texting me.
I'm like,
fuck that dude.
I'm not falling for it.
Jamie texted me.
I'm like,
I'm not falling for it.
You texted me,
you go pro,
it's April 4th I'm like,
no,
but Dana,
I dated,
released a video and he's listed,
I'm sure he likes a good April fool's
joke,
but what are you like s'mores money and
pay per view buys?
You can't honey dick.
The fans are like psych.
It's back on,
right.
People are going to be pissed and the
bust.
That's a good point.
Who knows?
I don't think we know enough
future science.
Yeah,
that's what you're into.
I'm way in the future science.
I wish we lived in the future,
so that's where ghost fit in.
I just go,
I mean future science.
I think.
I just think time.
I think time is an illusion.
I think that I'm more,
do you ever see interstellar?
Yes.
I'm more in that zone.
That's that smacked of good science to
me.
I was like,
yes.
So when you say time's an illusion,
you mean like the watch is real?
Like if it says four 30 that's when the
movie starts,
right?
That's all real.
No,
that's just coordination.
That's it's,
it's within our species.
We're coordinating together.
We're working as an ant colony.
We're sending signals,
which happened to be time signals were
using math to coordinate.
But if you go underwater and hold your
breath for five minutes,
that's real five minutes.
No,
that's just when you run out of oxygen.
So that five minutes,
that is the counting of that time
doesn't mean anything.
Doesn't mean anything.
No,
it doesn't mean anything.
But if someone's five minutes late,
you're like,
bitch,
you're fine.
No,
it doesn't mean anything.
Well,
I'm never mad about that because I'm
always late.
Oh,
okay.
Hmm.
That's interesting.
Um,
well the only time supposedly is now and
everything else is just are pathetic
attempts at measuring it and trying to,
that's just coordination on like,
you know,
people,
like that's all we're doing.
Like how old are you?
Um,
you know,
and then that just means how crispy you
are from going around the sun.
That's not like really anything.
Sorry.
Yeah,
you're like,
sorry.
Right,
right.
Skin.
Cracklin you know,
like,
it's just kind of that and to me like
time is just,
it's just space.
It's like how far are you away from this
gravitational pull?
I think gravity is way more interesting.
I think time is just us coordinating
with math while we definitely are,
but it's also like when the sun's coming
up,
like check your watch,
six 15 sun's coming up.
That's a real thing.
We're just clocking a spin of an earth.
Yeah.
It's the same thing with the lungs under
water.
The earth spins.
I agree with you and disagree with you
at the same time.
Yeah,
that's fine.
I think you're right.
But I also think the fucking movie
starts at four 30.
That's another human putting on a movie.
It's true.
You're just coordinating with,
give me an example of time that is a
manifest thing outside of human
coordination.
Um,
well you could,
the oldest don't mean like
things happening,
right?
I mean time,
just time itself.
Like is that helpful in any way?
Other than for us?
I don't think it exists in the universe
really.
Okay.